do you like good food because i like
really good food i do like you like good
food so how do you judge a good
restaurant
i judge a good restaurant first of all
by the service okay um but two i love i
love spices and i love the ingredients
that go into things and and having a
different flair on you know you can go
to a chinese restaurant at a mexican
restaurant in a cuban restaurant but i
love
when they do like a spin on the
traditional types of food because it's a
it's a new experience and i what do they
call that there's a name for that right
the is it a fusion or it's like you know
when they mix it to exactly latin fusion
yeah yeah every restaurant i mean one of
my favorite restaurants in vegas is
chino poblano and it's like mexican food
plus chinese i was like i've never been
to a chinese
so you like spices you like mix you like
fusion yeah what else
well that's i think that is a big part
of it is making sure that you've got
this experience because people go out
for food and if you're going out it's
not just the food you're going out for
the experience have you ever gone to a
restaurant for the first time and then
walked out 30 seconds into it
have you gone to a restaurant you're
walking you're like you know uh
i'm looking at yelp
let's go let's go check this place out
okay you go to this place and i was like
guys
we gotta get out of here
so how do we judge it though that's
based on what that's based on no one's
there during lunch yeah right so you
judge a restaurant many times based on
if you're the only customer there at a
restaurant during you know prime time
there is something wrong with this
restaurant right okay i feel like you're
going somewhere with you i want to
i want to i want to i want to take what
you're saying and say okay fine
let's listen to
what florida is doing wrong and what's
going on over here and you know all this
other stuff how terrible the state has
been under desantis and all this others
okay sounds good from 2020 if you go
till 2022 today i lived in la 20-some
years i lived in dallas five years i was
in the army so i lived all over the
place and i've been here for a little
over a year and a half
since the guys taken office no matter
how much they've tried to trash this guy
everybody keeps moving here this place
is busy people are coming here from east
coast from new york from baltimore from
dc from chicago from l.a from from all
over the place they're coming here
california is losing people their first
net negative since 1851 new york's
losing people no matter what they say
they're losing people this place flipped
from purple to red so for someone that
just maybe a data person they may say
nikki it's great that you have those
bullet points that you go through with
the messaging you're saying but the data
simply doesn't back you up the data says
they're doing a great job in florida
what do you say to those people first of
all you kind of look at florida for a
couple of reasons people don't come here
because of desantis that that i did
did you i did and i'll tell you why in a
little bit i want you to finish but i
did um so but they come here because the
beautiful weather
because of our beaches
because of the diversity of our state
they come here because there's no income
tax
and so all those things and during the
pandemic there there was a influx here
to the state absolutely but the problem
is now that the people are here we have
no infrastructure there is no planning
of exactly how we're going to expand out
our state i mean look look at today we
have a tremendous amount of rain now i'm
born and raised here in miami this is
not a storm this is this is a rain we're
used to this this is
a saturday yeah but i was talking to the
mayor earlier today and some of our city
and county commissioners and there's
flooding everywhere there's flooding
everywhere and there's cars being
abandoned and and there's no
infrastructure there's no money there's
been no conversation about how to make
sure when all these people are moving
into our state how we're taking care of
the people that are actually living i
get that but so so that to me then
becomes
step three but step one is you know hey
we're attracting all this talent if you
have a company that you're recruiting a
lot of high best
engineers that want to come to you're
doing something right then all of a
sudden you get
3 000 new employees that are coming to
your company now you're like listen guys
we need 16 hr people we need software we
need this we need that we need coaching
we need you know we need all this stuff
but step number one is why do we get 3
000 engineers because when you said
something like uh people are now moving
to florida for desantis well then
perfect so let me flip it on you why are
people leaving a beautiful state like
california are they leaving because of
the weather is so bad are they leaving
because the beach is so bad i was just
in l.a last week the weather is sick
there's so many reasons to stay in
california people left california
because of newsom and many people came
to florida because of desantis the nba i
remember one nba first when the covet
first started everybody was talking
about
florida i cannot believe what they were
that at the breakers we weren't living
here yet they're not doing this they're
not doing that and then the nba black
lives matter awesome what are you guys
doing in your playoffs florida wait what
mm-hmm orlando state you bashed
you can only do your playoffs in one
state so
again going back to it i know you're
saying infrastructure but
wouldn't you agree like at a time like
this when you're running the guy has
done so many things right where a lot of
people across the country or families
they have kids they're sitting there
saying at least this guy's got backbone
because if his policies were bad why
would people move to florida it wouldn't
just be the weather the guy's done a lot
of good policies and i feel like i feel
whether you guys have some areas you
agree with or not of course he's going
to say some stuff that he says about you
when somebody asked him on a what was it
when he was doing the town hall meeting
she's just doing what she's doing on
social media he made the comments about
you i'm sure you saw that and you made
comments about him and i know you know
the comments because you've talked about
we'll get into that here in a minute as
well but wouldn't you give him a little
bit of credit of what what he's done in
florida last couple years
look you know i have said very clearly
you know when covett hit is covet hit
and i had actually called on him to
close on the state early because i knew
that if we closed down the state early
that we would be able to get open
earlier and that we had able to save
lives no he he sat down and didn't do no
that wouldn't happen though nikki i
gotta i gotta just jump in on that let
me just let me just jump in on this for
one second because i i very much
appreciate your perspective but i am
that person that fled new york city i
love my city i love new york city i was
there my whole life the last 20 years
i did come here
for because of desantis i was looking at
different states i was looking at states
that were fighting for people's
individual freedoms i was i have a
two-year-old i was very very bogged down
in new york city by not just the crime
by the fact that the police force felt
unsupported but by the mandates and by
the restrictions and the lockdowns and i
felt like
so much of that stuff was being thrown
out there to try to control people and
there wasn't science that backed any of
those policies and what you saw here at
first i looked from afar but what you
saw here was a guy who and i'm not a
republican i'm an independent and i'm
not someone who has a loyalty to
politicians if desantis says something i
don't like i'll be the first person to
to call him out on that but i saw a guy
who kept the state open so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]